avec alexis coulon cofondateur du monde
moderne bonsoir alex lee poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur un rt
france alors ce nouveau groupe 1 qui
s'inscrit peut-être dans la majorité
mais pour autant ça n'échappe à personne
que l'hémorragie continue comment
peut-on interpréter ses formes
on dira de prise d'indépendance bien on
peut l'interpréter comme des manoeuvres
politiciennes ce qu'ils sont j'avais
déjà dit sur cette antenne que la
république en marche avait réussi à
fédérer les seconds couteaux les
arrivistes les ambitieux chacun retrouve
un peu son groupe a envie de sortir de
ce de cette plaine de députés godillots
où il n'existe pas envie d'exister
il n'y a pas que françois bayrou qui est
faiseur de roi donc pourquoi pas créer
des groupes qui reste dans la majorité
attendant de voir les votes aujourd'hui
pas de motion de censure pas de votre
contre la majorité mais une possibilité
de faire monter sa cote pour être
ministrable ou bien de trouver un canot
de secours parce que la république en
marche et bien c'est quasiment fini
c'est une étiquette qui faisait honte
lors des municipales qui me fait
toujours il fallait se déguiser soudé
liste citoyenne ne surtout pas dire
qu'on faisait partie de la majorité
ce n'est plus vendeur c'est difficile à
défendre pour plusieurs raisons la
gestion de la crise du coc vide bien
entendu mais avant cela la réforme des
retraites et puis tous les couacs qu'on
a pu voir et entendre un paravent donc
je crois que c'est des manoeuvres de
gens qui souhaitent conserver un poste
d'élu lors de prochaines séances
ou simplement et bien pesé dans le jeu
de l'assemblée mais qui sont loin de
représenter finalement ce qu'elle pays
et ça pousse d'une vraie question ce
changement d'étiquette en cours de
mandat où est le respect du vote qui
leur a été donné quelle est la
légitimité de ces députés de jouer d'un
groupe à l'autre de passer d'une
étiquette à une autre ce jeu de veste
retournement de veste en fait il n'est
pas là pour faire honneur à la
démocratie puisque c'est une certaine
façon renoncé au vote qui a été celui
des citoyens qui a fait d'eux des
députés de la république en marche mais
on comprend en tout cas une forme dans
votre analyse peut-être d'opportunisme
l'assemblée en tout cas n'a jamais
compté autant de groupes
ça dit quelque chose oui c'est sûr luc
mélenchon qui disait sur une note
c'est le pire de la quatrième république
qui le parlementarisme à outrance ou le
pire de la vème république
la verticalité des modèles macron donc
on est vraiment dans une configuration
terrible où c'est encore une fois la
démocratie française qui en prend un
coup puisque autre chose parce que on
voit des jeux d'appareils on voit
quelque chose qui intéresse peu
finalement les électeurs les français le
dire mais à quoi joue ces gens là quand
est ce qu'ils vont faire des lois qui
utile quand est-ce qu'ils vont enfin se
rendre compte qu'ils sont déconnectés
cette interview de richard seurat un
hebdomadaire qui parlait qui pensaient
que les français pensent être gouvernés
par des élites éclairées
ça en dit long sur la déconnexion au
sein du palais bourbon qui va en pâtir
le plus finalement dans cette assemblée
notamment le groupe d'opposition là les
républicains ont d'autres groupes
peut-être d'autres partis d'abord la
reine puisque elle perd sa majorité
absolue et que c'est une hémorragie qui
continue donc difficile pour elle de
garder la face c'est compliqué les
autres ce groupe d'opposition parce que
derrière ces jeux politiciens et bien il
y avait ce que disait mounir mahjoubi en
le fait que la république en marche
devait organiser à la fois la majorité
et l'opposition donc c'est un jeu qui
permet de couper les ondes d'occuper le
débat public et de jouer à un faux débat
de faire en sorte que les réelles
oppositions disparaissent ou soient
poussés aux extrêmes et n'est pas voix
au chapitre
donc c'est extrêmement dangereuse c'est
encore une fois un déni de démocratie
je n'y vois pas forcément un bon présage
et ça pose la question de la dissolution
est ce que la sagesse qui seraient
celles aujourd'hui voyons ces
retournements des ces opportunistes
changé de camp chaque semaine est-ce
qu'il n'est pas temps de siffler la fin
de la récréation de dire que la
république en marche c'est fini ou si on
veut recommencer alors votons
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale et
voyons ce qui est sortie des urnes alors
gires ensemble c'est le nouveau nom de
ce mouvement de ce groupe
après écologie démocratie et solidarité
à la semaine dernière ces noms choisis
les mots ont un sens évidemment sarr
fait quoi le monde d'après on ça veut
dire qu'on agisse est pas forcément
avant fin c'est pas qu'on a du mal à
comprendre c'est des étiquettes c'est du
marketing on est on est plus dans une
démocratie du débat d'idées on est dans
une démocratie du slogan on est dans une
démocratie du sondage il faut en sortir
ces gens là font du marketing politique
c'est ce qu'a fait emmanuel macron c'est
un produit
je suis désolée la politique c'est pas
du savon c'est pas de la lessive c'est
pas des pâtes cdi des essais des idées
solide c'est des gens qui ont milité par
le passé c'est des gens qui savent ce
qu'ils se défendent qui défendent
quelque chose une vision de la société
là on a affaire à des gens qui veulent
simplement être élu est monté en grade
devenir secrétaire d'état puis ministre
puis que sais-je encore ça suffit je
crois que les français méritent mieux
que ce jeu d'enfant cette cour de récré
où finalement on oublie les intérêts
supérieurs du pays
merci alexis a pour lui un cofondateur
du monde moderne d'avoir été avec nous